[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Nick Wright host of first
things first afternoons on Fox Sports 1
also a host of what's right with Nick
Wright on iTunes and YouTube
how you doing Nick
well I'd be doing a little better if
fritzy you know actually gave you what I
told him to introduce me as he gave you
most of it oh boy or you just
self-edited post the first things first
comma America's most beloved Sports
television show afternoons on FS1 and
the rest he did send you you I did I I
included that fridge the absolutely
specifically said what do you want him
to introduce you as and I included that
line and it's not there I thought he was
being cute and facetious and playful and
like he didn't actually want me to have
you say that that's why I took that part
out oh we're gonna get serious now when
Nick writes on the show I learned my
lesson now we have journalistic
standards here my intro was a commentary
on rock music from 24 years ago and now
all of a sudden I was just trying to get
in the archives America's most respected
broadcaster calling my television show
America's most beloved and it would live
forever and fritzy robbed me of that so
thanks for that I apologize I did choose
to edit that out thinking he was just
being cute well fritzy is a journalist I
will say that oh yeah no doubt about it
okay so the uh tattoo that you got never
a doubt yeah there it is on camera all
right kind of awkwardly showing what's
the problem all right so uh did you have
to run this by the home office there
home office like the you're watching
sports no no no no no no no no no no
your wife well you know Dan I'm nothing
if not brilliant and the and the thing
about having a tattoo that says never a
doubt is it is subject to interpretation
and so I come home with it and my wife
sees it initially
what's that it's about you and me baby
that's what I brought up I brought that
up last hour you spin it yeah never a
doubt yeah what and you know what if you
know as some of your listeners have you
know posited what if one day
you know a more successful handsome
older broadcaster steals her away from
me now I have never a doubt on my arm
what is it about then well then it's
about my career my professional path and
when the Chiefs win the Super Bowl this
year the 20-0 part Gets Lost In The
Ether and it's like hey you know who had
a doubt not this guy never a doubt so as
is the case either with myself or my
beloved Kansas City Chiefs just can't
lose even when they lose they can't lose
everyone's like no Nick how do you feel
about the Chiefs I don't know better
than Bengals fans feel better than the
Bills fans feel who are finally catching
up to what I've been saying about Josh
Allen Ravens fans feel great about that
new passing game how do Steelers fans
feel Chargers still the Chargers Broncos
look like Nat Hackett had Incorporated
uh Sean Payton's body that's the same
team 10 penalty 16 points I'm feeling
great absolutely fantastic if you felt
that great about the Chiefs you should
have put 20 no
what am I going to say to my wife then
exactly
I mean you're talking a big game there
20-0 would have stood for something that
truly meant you believed in the Kansas
City Chiefs well I mean a man has his
limits and also it's a contact sport and
things like Travis Kelsey's knee and
Chris age and Chris Jones knucklehead
agents can get in the way of things but
I feel very good I feel very good right
now how do you feel about playing in
Jacksonville against the new and
improved Revenge game listen Revenge
game they they maimed Patrick Mahomes
one of the dirtiest plays in modern
sports history
uh and so that listen I my AFC
Championship Game pick is Chiefs Jags I
think the Jags are gonna have a top four
offense I would have picked Trevor
Lawrence to win League MVP but because I
had predicted that one of the teams was
going to literally go undefeated that
typically would get an MVP uh but I
think they win that game and I think
they're going to be just fine I
everybody
here's the here is an actual Earnest
opinion that I know people is going to
say say is crazy but I'm right
despite the loss
the Chiefs have more reasons for
optimism after that Lions game than had
they won the game 38-35 we know the
offense is going to be good because it's
always good oh what about without Tyreek
Hill they didn't have him last year the
most points most yards won Super Bowl
the question for this Chiefs team
is when you play seven rookies last year
on defense how good can the defense be
and I thought the defense without Chris
Jones without their big free agent
acquisition Charles a minute who's
suspended for another five games looked
really damn good against a good offense
and a great offensive line in Detroit so
I feel I I am confident that this should
be the best defense the Chiefs have had
since Mullins has been there which is
why I thought they were going to go 20-0
but even though that's dead I feel
really good about it so I think they go
to Jacksonville and win and I think they
have I think I I'd get this tattoo but
it'd be too you know kind of arduous and
long I think that they're going to be
seven and one when they face the Miami
Dolphins and what will be a massive
football game right before the Chiefs
buy you still have the Jets going to the
AFC title game
I said Jags I had Chiefs Jacks I'm
saying I picked Chiefs Jags before the
year I had the Jets before the year
finishing last in the AFC East
and the it's a weird thing with the jet
stand because that because of the type
of injury
and I think all of us wanting to show
respect to Rogers and feel terribly
about the gravity of it
I don't think there was enough time
spent on the fact that Aaron Rodgers
getting dinged not at torn Achilles but
a high ankle sprain or something was
always the concern for a team that
addressed everything but their offensive
line and now nobody thought it would
last four games but I thought that this
was a potential outcome from the very
beginning especially when you're right
tackle hadn't played in two years and
your left tackle is Aaron's age like
that was a recipe for disaster from the
beginning unfortunately we're talking to
Nick Wright host of first things first
afternoons on Fox Sports 1 what's the
official introduction there Todd
I deleted the text but it had to do with
the most watched uh awesome information
almost watched I don't lie pardon the
interruption which gets no you know none
of the none of the sports media pundits
talk about pti's ratings they just get
you know the most the most views for 25
years nobody cares not a lot of viral
Clips I'm we're not the most watched
we're the most beloved and you know how
I can prove that because it's a feeling
it's in the air you walk through the
city and you're like you know what they
love us
show me it can't be debunked
can't be debunked exactly it's like
calling Dan Patrick America's handsomest
sportscaster hey
and no one can prove it's not true Joel
Clapp might have something to say about
it but you know
I don't know what no I I was gonna say
you know you're not the only person in
your house who would probably agree with
you okay
[Laughter]
you know my house gets smaller by one
today Dan I was gonna ask you about this
all fear do it on the air in 10 hours I
drive to the airport take my daughter to
college I'm in a bit of emotional
shambles about this situation yeah
here's the thing
don't like you want to show confidence
in her you show confidence in her by not
being emotional like you're gonna miss
her you love her uh you know I'm gonna
come and see you uh I wouldn't dump her
off curbside
um you know I would I would walk her you
know as far as you could but you'll show
confidence in her by your emotions and
your reaction because you might think oh
my God she's going to be like Dad it'll
be okay like don't cry
you're going to be like hey
I can't wait to hear what it's like
first week or so and I'm gonna come and
visit you make sure you stay in touch
what do you think that is Dan
exceptional advice
and I genuinely appreciate it good that
is great advice that can only come from
a much much
older person than I am yeah that has
been through it and understands these
circumstances thank you for that you're
welcome uh the NBA policies load
management
yeah um
how do we I I'm still trying to figure
this out how does this work where are
you going to say you got to play or an
independent doctor is going to look at
somebody or can I play for three minutes
and then sit down you know do I meet the
requirements of like I
this is this is challenging to say to
the team you got to make your players
play
it is challenging I'm not so concerned
about the all right I'll play for three
minutes and then sit down because if
players will hate that because it wrecks
your numbers like that's always been the
thing like oh just check and then go out
well then you get zeros across the board
and it hurts your averages and
everything so I think players will push
back against that uh so I don't think
that'll be so much of a concern here's
the thing there is not a perfect fix
here but we have right now diamet
diametrically opposed incentives
teams believe that their number one goal
is to have their players as healthy
rested and available as possible for the
postseason that actually is not the
number one goal the number one goal is
make sure the NBA stays incredibly
popular incredibly profitable and
Incredibly highly rated did everyone
complaining like oh you're going to make
special rules for the national league
televised games you're damn straight
that's what pays the bills and that is
that's the reason I think I've said this
to you before I'll make the point again
there is nothing inherent about
basketball that makes it more valuable
than frisbee golf but the reason the
best basketball players in the world
make 60 million and the best frisbee
golf players in the world have a regular
job is because the American public
values with our eyes and time one more
than the other when you have things that
are happening that are making the
American public turn away you have to
fix it and so I don't think it is I I
don't think I hate to come on and be
like there is no perfect solution I
don't think there is a perfect solution
but I think you have to step in the
direction of having the the television
and in stadium product better than what
it's been the last few years so I give
the lead credit on that regard and the
other thing that is sort of lingering
there like there's two things Joellen
bead at some point has to look around
and go what am I doing here and Giannis
has to look around at that roster and go
these guys are all in their 30s like
what am I what am I doing here which one
is more likely to be on a different team
sooner
suit okay so the the I think it is
almost a certainty
that Giannis leaves but I don't think
it'll be early I think Giannis will
finish the last two years of his
contract maybe win another title and
then leave like the if you're Milwaukee
you did the right thing you went all in
on this the best player in the league to
win a title but there's a cost to that
you went all in on veteran players who
have gotten older because you've been so
good you haven't been able to draft
great players that's that's the cost
embed I think there is a chance he
States but if he doesn't it's a he's
gone in a year does that mean do you
follow what I'm saying like I don't
think there's any chance Giannis has
gone a year from now I think there's a
real chance Giannis is or that I think
it's almost a certainty honest has gone
in two years and he's being open about
this and it's his right like he's not
wrong that I've done everything right
for Milwaukee I think they could win the
title and it could be the right decision
for him to eventually leave indeed you
have to see what return they get for
Hardin and they will get something at
some point and then for embiid who I
like a lot
then embiid has to actually have a
playoff run where he's awesome that
hasn't happened and he is now the only
there's only four MVPs in league history
that never made an NBA Finals actually
three now embiid Nash Rose I might be
leaving one out but I don't think I am
embiid's the only one who's never made a
Conference Finals so he at some point
has to take some ownership of this as
well
good good to talk to you
um yeah I hope you hope everything's
good uh Todd you have the official title
of his shows the most beloved show on
not only FS1 but anywhere in the sports
industry oh how's that yeah the most
America's most beloved Sports television
show seven words it's very easy and
maybe you should get that tattooed by
the way I'm still waiting for um your
dinner response I owe you a dinner I
asked you if we could do it Dan
responded with a smile Emoji Dan
responded to a question with a smile
Emoji that's not an answer
um yeah uh welcome to the club Nick yeah
that's how Dan that's how Dan
communicates but if it was at least you
got a smile Emoji not just the letter K
but but if it's a if it's a smile that
means I'm up for it if it's a frown that
means I'm not so no that's true I mean
you know what it was a good step
public pressure on you in order to make
this happen that's all
um all right next time the Chiefs lose
then we'll go to dinner and I'll pick up
your spirits so in two years I mean come
on oh they're good they're going
undefeated the rest of the year
19-1 that did you not see that part of
the tattoo see you fine thank you bud uh
that's Nick Wright uh he's popular he's
beloved he's a lot of things there and
he's got a tattoo
never a doubt all right